Kriminalitätsstatistik jahrelang lief
das eigentlich immer in die andere
Richtung so nach dem Motto wird
eigentlich immer besser gab auch immer
wieder böse Zungen die sagten das ist
nicht die ganze Wahrheit weil wenn man
nicht so genau hinguckt dann hat man
halt auch nicht so viele Fälle und dann
kann man immer wieder sie nicken es ist
so ja wir wollten das alles gar nicht so
genau wissen
möglicherweise die
polizeilichkriminalstatistik bildet
eigentlich nur das ab was wir im letzten
Jahr der Staatsanwaltschaft als Polizei
übergeben haben Hellfeld wir reden vom
Hellfeld und man muss wenn man diese PKS
in Kurzform wie sie genannt wird
bewerten möchte dann muss man eine ganze
Menge Dinge im Hintergrund auch Wissen
dazu das heißt ich muss wissen dass
erstens die Polizei die
Kriminalstatistik nicht die aktuelle
Kriminalitätslage abbildet sondern im
Prinzip man könnte jetzt bösartig sagen
beschäftigungsnachweis der Polizei des
letzten Jahres ist
also wenn man ehrlich ist sind diese
Fälle die wir auch in der polizeilichen
Kriminalstatistik tatsächlich erfassen
ja nicht Fälle die dann durch einen
Gericht verurteilt werden also wir haben
im Prinzip keine Verknüpfung der Taten
die wir in der PKS ausweisen und eine
anschließenden Anklage und einer
Verurteilung die Forderung die an der
Stelle zu zu machen wäre wäre die
sogenannte verlaufsstatistik dass wir im
Grunde genommen von der
Anzeigenerstattung bis zur Aufnahme der
Ermittlungen bei der Staatsanwaltschaft
bis zu einer Verurteilung durch ein
Gericht und auch dann der
präsozialisierung dass wir im Prinzip
eine Verlauf haben eines Kriminalfalles
dann hätten wir ein Bild aber das deckt
immer noch nicht das ab was wir jetzt
haben deswegen hohes Dunkelfeld in
vielen Bereichen schwieriges Terrain und
wird in der Öffentlichkeit halt auch
sehr viel leider Gottes von Menschen
kommentiert die sich mit der
tatsächlichen Grundlage noch gar nicht
so richtig auseinandergesetzt haben
sondern mehr sage ich mal Meinung als
Ahnung dann in den
vordergrundspeicherung und all die Dinge
über die wir gleich sprechen werden
das ist schon eine Ansage 11 ,5 % mehr
Straftaten als im Jahr zuvor was hat Sie
am meisten überrascht
also erstmal ist das richtig was der
Pinguin gesagt man muss auch die Dinge
im Zeitverlauf sehen und was wir
festgestellt haben dass wir in den
corona-jahren bei bestimmten Delikten
ein Abwärtstrend hatten
und das jetzt vieles leider nachgeholt
wird oder sich wieder normalisiert das
erklärt aber manchmal alles
zurück im Dienst sozusagen das zweite
was wir glaube ich noch viel besser
verstehen müssen und da will ich jetzt
nicht in die Kategorie von Politikern
hineingeraten ja Pedro geschrieben hat
die mehr Meinung als Ahnung haben ich
glaube wir müssen da wirklich die Verein
steigen ich glaube dass wir in der
Gewaltkriminalität von Jugendlichen auch
nicht alleine aber ein Phänomen sehen ja
dessen oder eine Folge dessen sehen was
wir den jungen Menschen in den
corona-jahren angetan haben wir kennen
alle die Statistiken bei Suizid bei
Depressionen und wir wissen aus der
Medizin dass diese Phänomene häufig auf
ähnliche Ursachen zurückzuführen also
die Aggression gegen sich selbst bei dem
einen Menschen ein Symptom ist aber die
selben Ursachen bei anderen Menschen die
Aggression gegen andere Menschen
triggert und das ist erstmal eine
Arbeitshypothese wir sind da noch nicht
so weit das gesellschaftlich fundiert
wirklich als klare Aussage stellen zu
können aber das ist eine These die im
Moment sehr viele Wissenschaftler und
auch Politiker umtreibt dass wir nämlich
neben dem Problem in dem
Bildungsbiografien in der
ausbildungsbürger viel in den
Krankenakten junger Menschen jetzt auch
in den Polizei und staatsanwaltsakten
junger Menschen sehen dass diese
unfassbare Belastung diese unfassbare
Zumutung ganze Lebensläufe durcheinander
schüttelt und auch Menschen offenbar auf
die schiefe Bahn geleitet hat von Gewalt
unter Jugendlichen das ist das von dem
sie sagen da haben wir ein Thema
absolutionale noch ein bisschen
konkretisieren weil wir uns bei uns im
investigativ die mir auch immer viel mit
diesen Fragen beschäftigen Gewalt
Entwicklung und wie ist die statistisch
zu erklären ähm ein Punkt über den sie
glaube ich gerade ein bisschen hinweg
gegangen sind ist so diese Frage also
erstmal ganz einfach sind die Leute
jetzt wirklich durch Corona so
geschädigt dass sie dann Gewalt hatten
begehen das ist ja erst der nächste
Gedankenschritt der erste der das in der
Statistik erklärt ist erstmal ganz
einfach solche Dinge wie wir kürzlich
abgefragt bei den Bundesländern wie
haben sich Gewalttaten an Schulen
entwickelt vielleicht durchschüler und
da lese ich feststellen dass es einfach
eine Delle nach unten gab weil während
Corona so lange die Schulen geschlossen
waren und jetzt wo sie wieder Aufsehen
auf sind geht es dann eben im Vergleich
zu den vor corona-jahren wieder hoch
also das ist denke ich so ein Punkt
das ist nicht einfach so sein muss die
Leute sind Corona geschädigt und
deswegen werden sie jetzt Gewalt da
hatten wir schon vorher ein Thema
das heißt durch Corona sind gewisse
Straftaten einfach erstmal
zurückgegangen was erstmal Glück war
aber das Thema gab schon vorher
wie erklären Sie sich das die die
Anstieg also dieses Thema Jugendgewalt
Leuchten Bürgermeister von Heide gehört
der sagte wir haben seit mindestens
einem Jahr ein echtes Thema wir kriegen
es kaum noch in den Griff so war
sinngemäß seine Aussage das ist
eigentlich ein Argument dafür dass wir
bei der Bewertung eines eines
Kriminalitätslage Bildes nicht nur
polizeiliche oder oder justizielle Daten
brauchen sondern auch Daten von zum
Beispiel Menschen die in der
Psychotherapie unterwegs sind Psycho und
Psychologin Psychologen wir müssen
einfach da mehr die Wissenschaft auch
beteiligen und Kriminalität Bilder auch
abzubilden wir müssen Dunkelfeld
erforschen wir müssen bei den
Jugendlichen natürlich das ist denke ich
schon in relevanter Faktor auch wenn er
noch nicht hinreichend untersucht ist
das natürlich die Corona ja Jahre auf
Kinder und Jugendliche eine besondere
Auswirkungen hatten die möglicherweise
dann diese nachholen ja die
möglicherweise dann bei der bei der bei
mir mehr frei Träumen natürlich dazu
führten schlichtübergreifend erstens
mehr tat Gelegenheiten weil die Leute
wieder auf der Straße sind das haben wir
in anderen deliktsbereichen auch
festgestellt und dass wir natürlich dann
auch Druck auf die auf diese jungen
Menschen eben die sie den sie ertragen
mussten der dazu führen kann dass eben
mehr sich dann auch mit körperlicher
Gewalt auseinandergesetzt wird so aber
das müssen wir wenn wir jetzt aber dann
noch mal schauen wie die Zahlen im
Vergleich zu 2019 sind das hat der
BKA-Präsident der Münchner auch erwähnt
oder gesagt dass wir da eher ein
moderaten Anstieg haben das muss das
gehört auch zur Wahrheit also der
Vergleich mit vor Corona polizeiliche
Kriminalstatistik und jetzt ist ein
anderer wieder Vergleich mit 2020 und
2021 für die Zuschauer sagen diese
Anstieg von etwas mehr als 11 %.
relativiert sich wenn man auf wenn man
den Vergleich zu den Jahren sind sind es
33%. aber ich will damit nicht sagen
dass man deshalb sich nicht mit dem
Phänomen beschäftigen muss
Jugendkriminalität ist ein relevantter
wichtiger Faktor und wir tun gut daran
das zu tun was der Pico gesagt hat
dass wir einsteigen in die Frage wie
kommt das welche Gruppen gibt es und wie
kann man gezielte Strategien am besten
für die Prävention entwickeln das ist am
besten nicht nur Repressionen gibt wenn
das Kind schon im Brunnen gefallen ist
sondern dass wir dafür sorgen dass
Menschen erst gar nicht auf die schiefe
Bahn geraten wie schauen Sie darauf vor
was Bach
also der Umgang mit Kindern und
Jugendlichen und ihren Familien in der
corona-pandemie der wird uns einfach
sowieso noch lange beschäftigen das kann
auch eine Folge sein wir haben vorher
Daten gesehen über die Entwicklung der
Schule schon Leistung also wo ganz klar
auch Spuren zu sehen sind und
hinzu kommt einfach das wenn man sagt
wir müssen präventiv anfangen da geht es
dann eben auch um wie gut sind die
Schulen wie gut sind die Schulen
ausgestattet wie gut sind die
Kindergärten ausgestattet wie gut
funktioniert Betreuung wie gut
funktioniert Integration also das sind
ja diese ganz klassischen Themen wo man
sagt da fängt da fängt das an ja das ist
das ist zum Beispiel gut dass sie gerade
ansprechen
die Frage mangelnder Konsequenz auf die
Frage von Integration sie haben neulich
im Bundestag eine Flamme der Rede auch
gehalten und sagten der Rechtsstaat sie
haben diese Metapher vom vom Tiger und
den Zähnen und so weiter benutzt glaube
ich so war sie erst wir haben natürlich
die Zähne die wir zeigen können als
Rechtsstaat die Frage die viele Menschen
umtreibt ist warum tun wir es dann nicht
so und das ist der Punkt auf den ich
antworten möchte ich finde es gibt
von der Gruppe der Leute geschrieben die
viel Meinung und wenig Ahnung haben es
gibt dann immer Leute die sagen wir
müssen die Strafgesetze immer weiter
verschaffen und noch mehr gesagt das
haben sie nicht gesagt aber das wird
häufig genannt wir haben eigentlich
Strafgesetze die eine sehr
strengewehre ermöglichen und es ist so
ich muss als Bundesjustizminister immer
aufpassen eins wenn ich einzelne Urteile
kommentieren würde dann würden Leute
wieder sagen wir haben aber
Gewaltenteilung du bist Regierung halte
ich aus der Justiz raus ich will nur
schon sagen wir haben diese Strafraum
und ich würde mir wünschen dass sie
Schuld angemessen auch
ausgereizt werden also wenn im
Strafgesetzbuch steht dass wenn man
Polizisten angreift wenn man die in
einen Hinterhalt lockt wenn man versucht
die zu verletzen dann haben wir
Strafgesetze die es ermöglichen bei
schlimmen Fällen die Leute auch sehen
oder 15 Jahre ins Gefängnis zu stecken
das passiert und das ist etwas wo man
schon daran erinnern kann dass das bei
schlimmen Fällen auch mal passieren
sollte und zwar einmal aus Respekt vor
dem Gesetz aber auch aus Respekt der
Personen die diese Gesetze schützen
sollen und das es Menschen gibt die von
Berufswegen sich immer wieder in
Gefahrensituationen begeben müssen und
das auch tun und dass die dort immer
wieder gefährlichen Situationen
ausgesetzt sind und wenn die dann den
Eindruck haben dass wenn an ihnen
Straftaten verübt werden und die dann
nicht ordentlich geahndet werden dass
das natürlich Frust auslöst das kann ich
sehr gut verstehen und deshalb kann ich
nur appellieren an alle Gerichte nutzt
die Strafraum aus die der Rechtsstaat
auch zur Verfügung stellt Beispiel
uns in Neukölln ist so eins was sehr
eindrücklich gezeigt hat wie wenig diese
theoretischen Möglichkeiten wirklich
ausgeschöpft wurden in dem Fall also ich
fand mich hat sehr beeindruckend es
waren zwei Reporter aus meinem Team in
Neukölln unterwegs in den Tagen danach
haben mit haben sich da umgeguckt in den
Häusern und dann wirklich mit jungen
Leuten gesprochen die dann ganz offen
gesagt haben ja ich war da auch dabei
und da ist nichts passiert ach ja da hat
die Polizei irgendwie ja meine
Personalien aufgenommen und ach und dann
merkt man einfach wie wenig Respekt die
dann haben vor den vor den Polizisten
und vor den strafentwicklungsbehörden
und ähm was ist das für eine Wirkung hat
das ja fatal wenn man das Gefühl man
kann da machen was man will das passiert
nicht
ihre Kollegin ihre Kollegen das war
viele übrigens selber mit
Migrationshintergrund man musste auch
immer sagen es gibt doch in diesem Land
eigentlich in Wahrheit eine große
Erfolgsgeschichte von Migration vieles
ist ja trotzdem mühsamer Umstände und
Dinge die wir nicht vorhersehen konnten
25 16 zum Teil und andere ist ja
wirklich gut gelaufen und ich bin im hat
mit mit vielen Menschen die die eben zum
Teil noch nicht mal deutschen Pass haben
und die mir sagen warum seid ihr da so
lasch warum geht ihr da nicht klar gegen
vor diese Leute müssen verstehen dass
das für sie eine Konsequenz hat wie
frustrierend ist das für sie nein man
muss jetzt solche Sachverhalte wie
Neukölln muss man muss man genauer drauf
schauen das sind vielfach tumult-delikte
wo wir eben eine schwere Nachweisbarkeit
haben dass eine Person jetzt irgendein
Gegenstand auf Polizeibeamten
Polizeibeamte geworfen hat kennen wir
aus dem Demonstrationsgeschehen also der
Nachweis der Straftat ist ungleich
schwerer als wenn wir jetzt im sag mal
face to face Infight sind um das mal so
zu nennen und es kommt zu einem
Widerstand dann ist ja klar wer die
Gewalt gegen die eingesetzten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ausübt was wir
aber wahrnehmen ist im täglichen Dienst
dass wir Kontrollen machen in
irgendeiner Stadt in Deutschland und
eben weniger das Problem besteht mit
denen die kontrolliert werden sondern
vielfach das Problem mit denen die bei
dieser Kontrolle hinten drumherum stehen
und da werden dann Gegenstände
geschmissen da werden die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen abgepöbelt es wird versucht
diese Kontrollmaßnahmen
erzählen wir uns eigentlich diese
Geschichten und wie lange wollen wir
sozusagen
aber unsere Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
so eine Kontrolle durchführen sind in
dieser Situation alleine gelassen und
müssen diese Kontrolle jetzt zu Ende
bringen und müssen unter Umständen
Verstärkung anfordern die sich dann nur
damit beschäftigt die Menschen die
drumherum stehen und uns erklären Beruf
zu machen haben ja meistens auch noch
alkoholisiert und dergleichen wir kennen
das ja aus den entsprechenden Hotspots
der deutschen Städte das polizeiliche
Maßnahmen immer dazu führen dass es
Menschen gibt die glauben sie wissen
alles besser und müssen uns erklären was
wir jetzt dürfen nicht dürfen und das
wir zeigen euch an wir filmen euch und
so weiter also ich finde es ist halt
eine zunehmend eine Eskalation von
verbaler Attacke gegen Polizeikräfte die
eingesetzt sind und wir merken es
natürlich auch bei solchen Geschichten
wenn die Möglichkeit besteht in einer
geschützten Gruppe möglicherweise gegen
Einsatz oder Rettungskräfte auch
vorzugehen
benutzt man das das sind auch wieder
Menschen gefragt die nicht bei der
Polizei sind sondern andere berufliche
Profession haben um zu untersuchen woran
liegt das ich kann Ihnen aber sagen
woran es nicht liegt nicht an der
Herkunft also Kriminalität ist nicht sag
ich mal eine Frage der Herkunft sondern
Kriminalität ist eine Frage der
Sozialisation der seriös in dem man sich
bewegt der Freunde die man hat und das
sollten wir doch immer wieder auch
deutlich sagen wenn wir über das Thema
flüchtlingsausländerkriminalität und
ähnliche Punkte sprechen
wir müssen darüber sprechen das
verständlich aber wir müssen das den
ganzen setzen machen und wir können
natürlich bei diesem ganzen Thema immer
auch müssen wir darauf schauen von
welcher Altersgruppe sprechen wir und
wenn wir von Flüchtlings oder Ausländer
Kriminalität sprechen dann reden wir oft
von Menschen männlichen Jugendlichen
zwischen 17 und 27 die eben das ist eine
kriminologische Binsenweisheit auch
unter den deutschen eben eher dazu
neigen Straftaten zu begehen das ist
einfach so das ist jetzt keine Sache von
Herkunft sondern eine Sache das Alters
männlich die dann eben auch eine Rolle
die muss man immer mit einbeziehen bei
der Betrachtung dieser Fragestellung
diese Gruppendynamik also wir beobachten
das in so verschiedenen Problembezirken
in Berlin gibt zum Beispiel diesen
gräfe-kiez wo schon seit
Generationen sozusagen die die
Gewaltbereitschaft in diesen Gruppen
immer weiter gewachsen ist und die
überhaupt keinen Respekt vor
Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft haben was
aber auch unter anderem daran liegt dass
die Erfassung dieser Taten nicht so
perfekt ist also wenn ich jetzt nur
polizeilich in Erscheinung trete weil
ich zum Beispiel ein kleines drogendelik
gemacht hat weil ich ein bisschen
gedealt habe oder weil ich mal jemand
angepöbelt habe und vielleicht nur
leicht verletzt dann bin ich erstmal gar
nicht in der zentralen
bundesweitenerfassung zum Beispiel drin
sondern erstmal nur in meinem
Polizeibezirk und erst ne in der
weiteren Eskalationsstufe komme ich dann
eben in die bundesweit Polizei Statistik
die dann dazu führen könnte das wirklich
eine Abschreckung stattfindet das heißt
im Grunde genommen das wird dann so
erfasst in Berlin in meinem Bezirk und
da passiert gibt nichts weiter und diese
Erfahrung die sich dann von Jahr zu Jahr
und Generation zu Generation
weiterbildet in Verbindung mit der
Gruppendynamik dass die Polizei einem
eigentlich nichts anhaben kann die
später mit Sicherheit eine große Rolle
wobei man eben auch Dinge tun kann also
wir haben jetzt sozusagen über Beispiele
gesprochen wo wir alle eine große
Unzufriedenheit verspüren ich will mal
na ja
meine wenn wir doch alle als
Gesellschaft auch als Arbeitsmarkt der
Meinung sind wir brauchen Zuwanderung
die brauchen wir dringend weil sonst
wird dieser deutsche Wohlstand so in den
nächsten Jahren nicht zu halten sein
aber wenn wir doch Akzeptanz dafür
wollen dann müssen wir doch auf der
anderen Seite bei denen die erkennbar
nur Mist bauen einfach mal Konsequenzen
wollte ich ja ein Beispiel gerade sagen
weil wir jetzt über Konstellation
gesprochen haben die uns zurecht
unzufrieden machen mit dem was die wir
auch nicht hinnehmen dürfen ein Beispiel
bringen aus meinem Heimat Bundesland ich
komme ja selber aus dem Ruhrgebiet aus
Gelsenkirchen dort haben wir auch
Probleme mit kleinen Kriminalität das
haben wir Gastronomen berichtet
Grundschullehrer berichtet werden
jedenfalls in der alten schwarz-gelben
Landesregierung regelmäßige
radzieherprogramme über die haben sich
einige am Anfang lustig gemacht aber die
sehr starke Präsenz auch das stören
kriminogenen Verhaltens oder also
sozusagen wenn Deals angebahnt werden
man konnte das nicht mehr so offen
machen weil die Polizei im Stadtbild
immer wieder gezielt aufgetaucht ist das
hat nach Rückmeldung vieler
Grundschullehrer Gastronomen das sind
immer so ganz feine Sensoren weil wenn
in den Familien was nicht funktioniert
dann wird es in die Grundschulen
getragen die Grundschullehrer sind die
kriegen sehr schnell mit ob was nicht
funktioniert und auch die Gastronomen
wenn die Aggressivität da ist wenn
Schlägereien stattfinden wenn Zeche
geprellt wird wenn das nach oben geht
das merken die sofort die merken da
stimmt was nicht und als das regelmäßig
stattgefunden hat auch in meinem
Wahlkreis habe ich von ganz vielen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern aus diesem
Berufsgruppen die Rückmeldung bekommen
das macht Eindruck
die Leute halten sich zurück sind
weniger aggressiv die merken ich kann
nicht mehr machen wie ich möchte dass
solche Programme erfolgreich sein können
das lernen wir daraus und deshalb müssen
wir wie sie sagen die Dinge auch
benennen ich finde es auch offen
gestanden nicht so erträglich dass wir
sehr viel darüber diskutieren und meinen
kleinen Kriminalität ist
Kleinkriminalität nennen darf oder nicht
sondern wir müssen zeigen dass wir
unsere Rechtsordnung ernst nehmen und
wer die Rechtsordnung mit Füßen tritt
der muss auch eine Konsequenz
verschwinden die muss immer in Relation
die muss immer Schuld angemessen sein
wir dürfen auch nicht übertreiben sonst
kann man junge Menschen die eben auch
mein Fehler machen können auch übermäßig
aus der Bahn werfen wir können nicht
jeden sofort ins Gefängnis werfen das
wäre auch nicht sinnvoll aber wir müssen
schon zeigen
Kriminalität angesprochen haben und
heute der Bundesjustizminister hier
sitzt die Verfahren die wieder alle
sehen
mal zwei Beispiele
ein mutmaßliches kleinmitglied wird an
der Medizinischen Hochschule in Hannover
wegen einer Schussverletzung behandelt
und muss zwei Wochen lang von der
Polizei bewacht werden Kosten
900.000 Euro für den deutschen
Steuerzahler ist das noch zu vermitteln
also ich kenne jetzt den Detail fallen
nicht und auch nicht die Akte habe
grundlegenden Kollegen von fraudow
wieder recherchiert ja ich will auch gar
nicht die Fakten in Frage stellen ich
will nur sagen wenn wir den Rechtsstaat
durchsetzen wollen dann kostet das
natürlich etwas Gefängnisse kostengeld
Prävention kosten Geld Polizisten kosten
Geld und
natürlich muss uns die Durchsetzung des
Rechtsstaates auch etwas wert sein und
wenn dieser Mensch möglicherweise in
Lebensgefahr schwebte weil andere ihm
möglicherweise vom Leben zum Tode
befördern wollten dann können wir das ja
auch nicht einfach hinnehmen und sagen
der interessiert uns nicht und wir
schauen uns wieder umgebracht wird das
will ich nur sagen natürlich kann man
solche Rechnungen aufmachen aber
prinzipiell wir sind ja ein Rechtsstaat
und deshalb muss uns die Durchsetzung
von Recht auch etwas wert sein anderes
Beispiel Bushido
der Prozess gegen Bushido wie finden sie
denn
wissen sie bushido ist ein Bürger wie
jeder andere auch und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass egal wer mit dem Gesetz in
Konflikten Schutz im Jahr mittlerweile
ungefähr 600.000 Euro kostet ja aber
Herr lands Kollegen von RTL recherchiert
ja aber sollen wir jetzt sagen wir
führen die Verfahren nicht durch oder
wirklich also es geht um die Art und
Weise wie sozusagen
mittlerweile bei 100 und wenn man den
Kunst Sachverhalt nimmt eigentlich
verhältnismäßig Meyer gewesen wäre mit
Stefan Müller dann wäre das
wahrscheinlich in einem Verhandlungstag
abgefrühstückt gewesen
Punkt
ich weiß was morgen los wäre wenn ich
jetzt anfangen würde Kopfnoten Pflanzen
Verfahren
unabhängig und ja Vorsitzende Richter
entscheidet wie er das Verfahren
erwartet und das wollen wir auch dass
die Justiz des unabhängig entscheidet
dass die sich auch die Frage stellen
muss was ist angemessen und was nicht
das ist in Ordnung aber das muss die
justizentscheiden wenn wir da jetzt als
Polizei oder Bundesregierung in
einzelnen Verfahren reinfunken würden
dann würde die Justiz sagen wir haben in
Deutschland gewartet die sich damit
auskennen ich bin kein Jurist aber sie
sind exzellenter juristik können das
beurteilen die sagen okay da hat Herr
Arafat Herrn Bushido mutmaßlich mit
einer Plastikflasche bedroht
und ihm gedroht ich hau die damit einmal
auf dem Kopf ich glaube es war eine
Glasflasche okay entschuldigung ich
nehme die Plastikflasche zurück es war
eine Glasflasche aber jetzt auch nicht
besonders beeindruckend dafür leisten
wir uns ein Verfahren über mittlerweile
100 verfahrenstage dafür leisten uns 600
000 € Kosten um Bushido und seine
Familie zu schützen
und am Ende wird um das Sagen
juristische Beobachter auch Vollprofis
so wie sie die sagen am Ende wird da
nichts bei rumkommen eine
Bewährungsstrafe schätzen sie auch so
ein eine Bewährungsstrafe das heißt es
geht eigentlich geht es um die Frage was
eine Plastikflasche oder eine
Glasflasche und die Frage wie gefährlich
kann so eine Glasflasche am Ende werden
auf dem Kopf von Bushido und die Fragen
kann man ist das verhältnismäßig das
frage ich mich einfach die Bürger und
Steuerzahler auch dieses Land es gibt
zwei es gibt zwei Perspektiven einmal
kann man an vielen Stellen grundsätzlich
Frage stellen ist das zu aufwendig
nehmen Sie das Jugendstrafrecht da kommt
auf der rechtsfolgenseite kommen ein
paar Tage Rest rum trotzdem sitzt ein
jugendtrichter sitzt ein Staatsanwalt
und ein Verteidiger drei Volljuristen
verhandeln darüber aber diese
Verhandlung selber soll ja auch im
Idealfall auch pädagogischen Eindruck
machen auf der und das zweite was ich
sagen möchte
das ist eine Frage der Umgang
mit Prominenten in Strafverfahren da
gibt es jetzt zwei Denkschulen ich meine
die müssten behandelt werden wie alle
anderen auch das würde aber nicht selten
dazu führen dass bei Verfahren von
prominenten Persönlichkeiten
Unternehmern auch Politikern
Staatsanwälte wenn es Hans Meyer wäre im
Regelfall sogar einstellen würden unter
Auflagen und Weisung das macht man bei
prominenten Personen aber nicht weil man
die Sorge hat dass dann möglicherweise
Journalisten sagen aha ein Promi-Bonus
eingestellt hat sich auch als im
ermitteln der Staatsanwalt oder Richter
profilieren dass man da besonders
zurückhaltend die meisten Richter die
ich kenne haben keinen Zug zu
Öffentlichkeit und empfinden das häufig
auch als eine Belastung weil die auch
ihr Deputat haben belastete
Geschäftsstellen haben aber ich glaube
es ist sehr häufig die Sorge dafür dass
wenn man Prominente im Strafverfahren
eins zu eins zu behandeln würde wie
andere dann würde man ihn sehr vielen
Fällen eine kleine Lösung machen und da
hat man die Sorge dass es dann heißt es
gibt ein Promi Bonus den es so gar nicht
gibt wie weit ist es gibt eher so eine
Art
Problem nicht dass jetzt so ein
promi-verfahren so lange dauert und so
absurde Dimensionen einem sondern ist
das Problem nicht dass diese vielen
vielen Verfahren die es auf Amtsgericht
sondern durch die Ebene gibt es die oft
so lange dauern das sozusagen zwischen
zwischen Straftat und und und Urteil
also quasi Konsequenz einfach so viel
Zeit vergeht dass da auch keine
Verbindung mehr
besteht ja logischen Charakter mehr
haben kann die Masse die Masse des
Problems liegt ja woanders also wir
empören uns gerne über so exponierte
Einzelfälle wo wir sagen das ist ja
wieder ein Beispiel für Deutschland ist
eine Republik Absurdistan aber
tatsächlich die unspektakuläre die in
den unspektakulären Niederungen da
liegen ja eigentlich die wirklich
relevanten Probleme gerade wenn wir über
sowas reden wie Jugendstrafe und so
weiter
dort muss man ja auch noch sagen
eben länger dauert ist das durchaus
strafmildernd zu berichten zu
berücksichtigen
erlanz hat der eben dieses diese
prominentenverfahren jetzt angesprochen
ich bin ganz Bein wir Beschleunigung und
ein Baustein ich sage nicht dass das
Siri machen ist aber ein Baustein ist
etwa die Digitalisierung dass wir immer
noch Papierakten haben mit roten
Umschlägen die wir durch die Gegend
schicken und die dann von aktenboden
durch die Gegend getragen werden das ist
etwas das ich habe mal gesagt die
sogenannten Gürteltiere so nennen
Juristen und Polizisten die dicken Akten
um die so ein Stoffgürtel gemacht werden
diese dicken Papierakten die müssen wir
auf der Liste der bedrohten Tier
einsetzen wir müssen im Bereich auch der
justizkonsequent digitalisieren das wird
nicht alle Themen der Beschleunigung
lösen aber das ist ein Beitrag